hallo liebe zuschauer herzlich
willkommen
wir wollen eine ganz besondere sache ist
ist die neujahrsnacht
wir nennen es in deutschland silvester
und an diesem tag feiern wir in das neue
jahr hinein das ist in deutschland ein
bisschen speziell es gibt ein paar
sachen die sind anders als in anderen
ländern das wollen wir euch heute
vorstellen
bei uns ist der roger roger wir freuen
uns roger wittmann pisa moderieren und
wir werden euch jetzt mal zeigen wie man
hier zum beispiel in berlin in
deutschland
silvester feiert sehr gern es da ich los
geht's
roger schweißen heute vorbereitet bist
aber silvester in berlin ist ja ich war
auch noch nie sehr westen was zwischen
silvester in berlin
ich war schon in berlin zu silvester und
ich freue mich auch dieses jahr hier
sein zu dürfen
berlin ist glaube ich ein bisschen irre
das ist ein bisschen wenn man nicht auf
solche ankommt ist silvester sowieso
schon komisch in deutschland ein
bisschen ich habe gehört von 9 ist ein
bisschen wie krieg das stimmt auf jeden
fall die kleinen hier schon ganz schön
laut man hört vielleicht auch ein
bisschen im hintergrund ist gescheppert
so heftig mal schreckt sich sehr schnell
man muss immer vorsichtig sein
ganz schnell passiert ist und es knallt
umschwenken wird hallo ihr lieben sollte
vorsitz
okay das ist ja schon mal nicht schlecht
grüße ich bin roger und du bist der
andere haie androsch kannst du mir sagen
was du dir für vorsätze fürs neue jahr
gesetzt hast ja ich will regelmäßig zu
mcfit gehen und ich sport treibe mich
auch für den sommer eine schöne figur
haben das ging doch das ging ganz gut
und wo hast du heute abend
ich war hier ich warte jetzt auf meine
freunde und dann wird dir gefallen hat
da wird geballert dass seine ansage oder
da müsste ich fragen was du viele
vorsätze fürs neue jahr
alle zu machen wie immer
sich wirklich nein
darf ich fragen was ihr euch für
vorsätze gewünscht hat für dieses jahr
noch gar kein eigentlich kommt das kommt
dass seine erst wenn's wenn es zwei vor
ort untersucht ich glaube ich euch
fragen wie oder wie du
wir gehen in die kulturbrauerei gute
vorsätze das übliche noch ein bisschen
weniger es ein bisschen mehr sport
machen
entschuldigung darf ich sie fragen wie
sie neuers tag verbringen ja in der
kulturwerkstatt okay an sich vorsätze
fürs neue jahr gesetzt
ich hoffe dass die gesellschaft
friedlich bleibt okay okay das ist ja
auch ein guter vorgaben frieden danke
das ist das wichtigste
hi
ja liebe leute sehr dir das da drüben
den w123 4588 mannschaftsbus von der
polizei große wagen mit ihrer sechs
sieben oder acht polizisten da drin
dieser kreuzung wir sind ja eberswalder
straße in berlin ist besonders viel los
das ist sowieso schon hotspot generell
zum feiern zu haus gehen jetzt an
silvester ist es noch mal mehr besonders
besonders viele leute sind es gibt auch
ein bisschen alters die bestimmung
manchmal viele leute sind hier viele
leute meinen feiern
nun könnt ihr es wisst wenn wir nach
deutschland kommen es ist ein bisschen
irre diese ganze stimmung her was habt
ihr euch für diesen abend vorgenommen so
wir wollen einfach spaß haben und uns
neue rutschen morgen wünsch dir was du
für viel glück gesundheit und einkommen
für party wirklich was wien studieren
was menschen im neuen jahr
einfach ein richtig geiles
ein bisschen geschockt platziert krieg
ihr habt ja eben schon gesehen dass wir
ein paar leute interviewt haben sie
gefragt haben dass sie nach ihren
neujahrswünschen und habe sie auch das
ein oder andere mal gescheppert aber
jetzt ist groß nur mit zustand kaum zu
fassen was wir erleben können
mit unserer interessiert ich denke es
ist wahrscheinlicher als macht uns ein
bisschen unterstützung
was spezielles in deutschland und was
man im international nicht hast im
englischen sagt meine happy new year vor
und nach silvester oder vor nachdem neun
jahren in deutschland hat man zwei
verschiedene wünsche man sagt guten
rutsch vor 24 uhr am 30.12 wo man sagt
gross nach mitternacht und wenn man
fußballer in deutschland
er sagt dann bringt das unglück der sexy
das heißt hallo
das heißt wenn man vorher sagt das kann
man nicht sagen was ist das spezielle an
spezielle sprache man euch wenn ihr
freund apple hier wünschen wollt müsst
ihr wissen ob ihr vor oder nach dem 31
12 00 uhr sinnvoll heißt es guten rutsch
und danach heiße spur ist